once steve jobs said everyone in this
country
should learn to program a computer
because it teaches you to think
most people including software
developers think that their job is to
write code
but actually it is more than that the
job of a software developer
is to solve problems so if you're
someone who is interested in software
development
or someone who's wondered what it means
to be and to think like a programmer
then this video is for you i will share
with you steps that you can take to
become more effective
in solving problems so why is this
important
because problem solving is the meta
skill
we all have problems big and small
how we deal with them is sometimes well
pretty random
unless you have a system this is
probably how you solve problems
step one you try a solution step two
if that doesn't work you try another one
step three if that doesn't work repeat
step two until you look out
to be fair sometimes you luck out but
you might already know by now
that this is the worst way to solve
problems and it is a huge waste of time
but what is the better way the better
way involves having a problem-solving
framework
and continuously practicing it almost
all employers prioritize problem-solving
skills first
in fact problem-solving skills are
almost unanimously the most important
qualification that employers look for
more than programming languages
proficiency debugging
and system design demonstrating
computation thinking
or the ability to break down large
complex programs is just as valuable
than the baseline technical skills
required for a job
so what should you do when you encounter
a new problem
you should act according to the
problem-solving framework which involves
three steps i'm going to discuss next
step one
know exactly what is being asked most
hard problems are hard because you don't
understand them
how to know when you fully understand a
problem when you can explain it
in plain english do you remember being
stuck on a problem
you start explaining it and you
instantly see holes in the logic you
didn't see before most programmers know
this feeling
this is why you should write down your
problem doodle a diagram
or tell someone else about it after all
if you can
explain something in simple terms you
don't really understand it
step two plan don't dive right into
solving without a plan
and somehow hope you can muddle your way
through plan your solution
nothing can help you if you can't write
down the exact steps
in programming this means don't start
hacking straight away
give your brain time to analyze the
problem and process the information
to get a good plan answer this question
give given input x
what are the steps necessary to return
output y
step 3 divide this is the most
important step of all do not try to
solve one big problem
instead break it into sub-problems these
sub-problems are much easier to solve
then solve each sub-problem one by one
begin with the simplest simplest means
you know the answer or
are closer to that answer after that
simplest means
this sub-problem being solved doesn't
depend on others being solved
once you solved every sub-problem
connect the dots
connecting all your sub-solutions will
give you the solution to the original
problem
congratulations this technique is a
cornerstone of problem solving
the third step is sometimes called the
reduce the problem technique
for example suppose you're a new
programmer and you're asked to write a
program that reads 10 numbers and
figures out which number is the third
highest for a brand new programmer
that can be a tough assignment even
though it only requires
basic programming syntax if you are
stuck
you should reduce the problem to
something simpler
instead of the third highest number what
about finding the highest overall
still too tough what about finding the
largest of just three numbers
or the larger of two reduce the problem
to the point where you know how to solve
it and write the solution
then expand the problem slightly and
rewrite the solution to match
and keep going until you are back where
you started
don't expect to be great immediately
after adopting this problem-solving
technique
if you want to be a good problem solver
you need to solve
a lot of problems you need to
continuously practice
this great technique but how do you
practice it
there are a lot of options out there for
you chess puzzles
math problems sudoku go monopoly
coding challenges and even video games
to
name a few a common pattern amongst the
most successful people
in the world is their habit of
practicing micro problem solving
so to think like a programmer you need
to cultivate a problem-solving skill and
practice it daily
now go solve some problems if you found
this video useful
i would appreciate it if you inflate the
like button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel for more videos and
click
on the notification bell enjoy the rest
of your day